Hey Bill,
my name is Thomas and I'm from Los
Angeles,
California.
And I was wondering if mathematics is
truly universal.
I'm not disputing it.
I'm just really wondering if,
uh,
mathematics such as calculus a really
like a,
it's the same near the edges of the
universe for all that we know,
or,
um,
like near black holes.
Does Matthew do mathematical laws?
Uh,
breakdown?
thanks
Thomas.
That is a great question about
mathematics as far as we know,
it works everywhere.
You know,
whatever,
if we go to a place,
as you suggested,
near a black hole,
the edge of the universe and mathematics
doesn't work.
We would say to ourselves,
well,
there's just mathematics that we don't
understand.
We have to add some more,
more math to our,
uh,
to our,
Kennan of mathematical equations.
It's very reasonable that there's math
that nobody knows how it works,
but just understand that when it comes
to the motion of planets,
when it comes to how rockets work,
when it comes to the paths of comets and
asteroids and meteors,
we understand this stuff inside out.
However,
it was only in the 16 hundreds that
these discoveries were made.
And so,
uh,
you'll also hear people talk all the
time about the singularity,
the singularity.
And this is to me,
is when you get one over zero and one
over zero is infinite,
or it is unknowable.
And I'll give you an example.
Uh,
what's,
what's 1000?
What's bigger?
One 10th or 1000th a 10th is bigger than
a thousandth.
Okay.
Then,
uh,
what's bigger?
1000th or one 10000th a thousandth has
bigger.
All right.
Now what about one over one 10000th
that's 10,000,
but at one over 1000000th is 1,000,001
over a billion visibility.
So as the number gets smaller and
smaller,
that total the inverse,
the,
uh,
denominator causes the total,
the quantity to become a bigger.
And so if it's over a zero,
it would become infinity or infinite.
And nobody knows what happens at
infinity.
No one knows what happens exactly at the
singularity.
Oh,
people speculate.
Oh.
Uh,
but yeah,
as near as we can tell,
math applies everywhere.
That is a great question.
Thank you.